Вже не один рік сільський голова Ганнусівки, що на Івано-Франківщині,
випрошує гроші в району та області на ремонт цієї амбулаторії.
У медичному закладі, який обслуговує три тисячі пацієнтів, ніде ні руки помити, ні в туалет сходити.
Ігор Лукашевич вважає: реформа децентралізації споконвічну проблему вирішила б.
Якщо добре логічно продумати, то береться так: питання по одному селі,
проблема в тому, в тому і в тому, а по іншому - в тому і в тому.
І бачимо, що і куди ми можемо спрямувати і підтримати.
От в Ганнусівці, дійсно, треба амбулаторію підтримати,
бо близько трьох тисяч населення обслуговується.
Створити об’єднану територіальну громаду тут не можуть понад чотири роки.
Усе ніяк не порозуміються з найближчими селами.
Поки одні селищні голови саботують децентралізацію, бо бояться втратити посаду,
інші рахують - скільки їм вже коштує таке зволікання.
Прикро, дуже дуже прикро,
бо ти аналізуєш і бачиш, що якщо ти зробив за свої кошти.
За два скликання - чотири дороги я проасфальтувала, то я прекрасно розумію,
що якщо б ми об'єдналися минулого року, то цього б року були дороги усі асфальтовані.
Не лише в Єзуполі, але й в усіх селах, що увійшли в ОТГ.
Аби заохотити українські села до реформи,
держава навіть надавала дотації на капітальний ремонт комунальних закладів, вулиць і доріг.
Цього року це майже 2 мільярди гривень на всі новостворені ОТГ.
Сусідня з Ганнусівкою та Єзупеолем Ямниця вже відчула користь від об’єднання.
Наприклад, за державні гроші тут заасфальтували дороги, почали укріплювати берегову лінію села
та розробляти проект каналізації для приватних будинків.
Про таке селяни і не мріяли.
Прогрес певний, ось бачте і дорога, і самий факт об'єднання - звучить.
Значить є спільні цілі, програма.
Футбольний стадіон із сучасним покриттям. А поруч зводять фітнес центр.
В планах, навіть, побудувати басейн.
Ямницька громада сама вирішує, на що витрачати гроші у першу чергу.
До цього часу бюджет 4 сіл був близько 30 мільйонів,
станом на сьогоднішній день вже близько 90 мільйонів.
Не знаю враження інших громад, які об’єднались,
але від Ямницької ОТГ можу сказати, що це є позитивом.
Оскільки більше 50 мільйонів, які йшли у бюджет районної ради залишається в громади,
і громада може активно покращувати інфраструктуру.
На території Ямницької ОТГ розташований потужний цементний завод.
Якщо десятиліттями громада була проти шкідливого виробництва,
то цього року ледь не вперше відчула переваги великого бізнесу.
Тепер податки завод сплачує не області, а громаді.
Та попри це, місцева влада шукає нові шляхи наповнення бюджету,
створюючи вигідні умови для бізнесу.
Підприємства, які були зареєстровані в Івано-Франківську,
так склались обставини, що їм краще буде працювати у нас.
Близько 200 робочих місць додатково у нас має бути залучено,
де податок з доходу фізичних осіб буде надходити до нас в бюджет громади.
В Єзуполі та Ганнусівці великого бізнесу немає,
тож надходження до їхньої майбутньої громади не порівняти з Ямницею.
Утім, навіть податку від заробітних плат бюджетників,
акцизів від заправок буде достатньо, аби збільшити бюджет сіл в рази.
Звичайно ми б хотіли, щоб об’єднання громад було у нашому селищі.
Моє і наших односельців побажання - центральної каналізації,
щоби були очисні споруди.
Покращиться може, може буде щось краще, може більш щось зроблять.
Дороги!
Аби процес об’єднання громад завершився до 2020 року, у державі планують змінити законодавство.
І від добровільного об’єднання перейти на обов'язкове.
В Єзуполі та Ганнусівці цю поправку до закону чекають з нетерпінням.
А поки думають, як дожити рік з мізерними дотаційним бюджетом.
Так, до кінця року, у скарбниці Ганнусівки залишилось всього 20 тисяч гривень.